le 26 janvier madame butin qui ministre
à l'époque dit qu'il n'ya pas de pénurie
le 4 mars
vous indiquez vous mais madame la
ministre on ne doit pas acheter de
masques nous avons donné des consignes
aux pharmacies le 17 mars olivier véran
alors ministre de la santé dit nous
avons assez de masques pour les
soignants et les malades alors qu'au
même moment les soignants qu'ils soient
chefs de service et donc envoyé sur les
plateaux mais aussi les organisations
professionnelles de soignants pointe du
doigt ce qu'ils appellent un scandale
sanitaire c'est à dire l'absence de
matériel et notamment de masques pour
les soignants et y compris pour les
soignants de ville alors vous même
à l'issue du conseil des ministres du 17
mars vous indiquez les français ne
pourront pas acheter de masques dans les
pharmacies
car ce n'est pas nécessaire si l'on
n'est pas malade et donc je voudrais
rapprocher l'ensemble de ces propos de
propos que l'on vous a apprêté lors de
votre prise de fonction au cabinet du
président de la république et vous
auriez dit j'assume de mentir pour
protéger le président de la république
ma question est donc très simple
avez-vous menti pour protéger le
président de la république dans cette
période
vous me posez la question par rapport à
des propos qui ont été prêtés je vais
donc à nouveau ordonner les
circonstances dans lesquelles ces propos
qui ont été rapportés de manière
parcellaire m'ont été prêté il
s'agissait du moment de la campagne
présidentielle et législatives ça va
être assez triviale vous allez le voir
le président de la république
au futur président de la république à
l'époque souhaitait faire une partie de
tennis un jour d'un week end électoral
sans meute de journalistes et
des journalistes se sont aperçus que il
avait quitté le lieu où il était pour
aller faire cette partie de tennis qui
était donc un instant privé qui qu'il
souhaitait privé et le journaliste
un journaliste en question m'interpelle
très très très très en colère
en me disant tu ne m'a pas donné la
possibilité d'accéder à ce moment très
important pour la vie politique
française de voir emmanuel macron faire
du tennis et ce à quoi je lui ai répondu
j'assume parfaitement de mentir quand il
s'agit de protéger un moment de vie
privée qui n'a rien à voir avec le
moment politique dans lequel nous sommes
c'est exactement les propos que j'ai
tenus je les maintiens
évidemment vous comprendrez bien que
vous le contexte dans lequel ils ont été
tenus ça n'avait rien à voir avec
d'éventuels enfin une éventuelle
décision de mentir sur les décisions que
pourrait prendre le gouvernement et donc
c'est évidemment la ligne que je me suis
fixé qui est une ligne attendue de la
part des responsables politiques
normal en démocratie à tout le moins me
semble-t-il est donc au cours de la
crise du coronavirus g dans le cadre de
mes fonctions systématiquement relayer
les informations qui étaient à ma
disposition conformément au décret
d'attribution qui étaient les miens et
conformément aux informations dont je
disposais de la part de mes collègues du
gouvernement et aux décisions qui ont
été prises dont je le dis encore une
fois je suis parfaitement solidaire